so viel fragt könnte die villa auch
verlassen und durch die stadt und
schauen dann müsst ihr tun die post in
der villa sollen sie das land verlassen
das ist einfach ihm zu gefallen
ich habe die ganze zeit auch so meine
runden welt geht du wirst irgendwann
verrückt herzlich kommt es immer wieder
leute herzlich kommen die zum teil 2
meines interviews mit lea die ganze
sache dreht sich wie jetzt auch den
titel schon gelesen hat darum dass lea
im jahr 2020 bei einem bachelor war und
jetzt weil einige fans gestellt wenn wir
jetzt beantworten viel spaß
kira fragt wisst ihr vor der nachricht
wirklich nicht damit auf ein date kommt
also man kann sich natürlich nur zwei
woche in der ich mein einzelwert hatte
auf der dachterrasse wann da vor 21
minuten fest und jeder aus dem kopf dran
außer ich und da saß ich dann natürlich
aus gefühlen sie sich vergessen sturz
zwischenfall von mir gab es ferner am
set
wenn die unterstrich keitel gab es ein
moment in dem die liebe zu den
kandidaten nicht gespielt war das so
formulierte seine frage wer behauptet
koch oder der denkt dass der große
moment gespielt ist was würdest du dazu
sagen also ich finde erst mal dass
madeline ist sehr werke natürlich fahren
durch gefühle auch unsere von meiner
seite aus haben sich auch für die
aufgewacht und hätte ich diesen mann nie
geküsst und so von den mädels mit denen
jetzt auch ängsten zu tun hatte
alles unterhalb nach was das war auf
jeden fall nichts gespielt ich mit ihnen
arbeite mit das machen dann muss brauche
ich ein bett im anderen da hätte ich
jetzt in der situation sind und das hier
weil sie gern nach mega er aber außer
aber ich habe keine karte erfahrung
auch das hatte frage von mindesten
punkte berührt doch gerade schon
angesprochen was denken deine eltern
ich habe einmal sehr viel selbst nach
gedacht alles wäre ich dass diese
entscheidung lassen nur für mich treffen
wollte und als ich die entscheidung
getroffen habe dass ich die bewerbung
los schicken möchte habe ich erst meine
mama darüber gesprochen und meint so ja
ich hab das schon wieder die krise
gekommen ist was ist denn jetzt schon
gehört und dann habe ich erst erzählt
und dann war die natürlich im ersten
moment nicht warum warum machst du jetzt
ausgerechnet im fernsehen einen mann
suchen die wahrheit glaube ich am
ehesten besorgt darüber dass ich schon
wieder traurig bin trink dass man aber
meine mama ist ein herzensguter mensch
und sie unterstützt mich in einem was
ich tue also sofort wieder
zusammengebaut etwas drauf sie war nicht
so begeistert ist wieder da mit dem
fernsehen geschleppt habe und es kommt
irgendwann habe ich zu hause
ausprobieren möchte ja und mein vater
hat es tatsächlich erster fand sich
wieder darauf gut so jetzt muss aber
sagen wir sind getrennt leben nicht mehr
zusammen hat jetzt auch im nachhinein
alles angebote hat immer taktik nie
gemacht mit freunden bei sich zu hause
ohne wird
das kostet doch mein umfeld
thomas ist toll ich bin so stolz auf
dich du verstellt sich nicht er möchte
auch ganz cool so viel fragt könnte die
villa auf verlassen und durch die stadt
und schauen dann müssen wir die prozesse
in der villa so du hast die villa noch
verlassen oder nur was er sagt ist
wirklich ja also betreutes wohnen muss
ja es ist betreutes wohnen das ist
einfach nur zu also das ist gefangen wie
sind bürger ich habe die ganze zeit auch
so meine welt du wirst irgendwann
vermutlich könnte dieses türkis nicht
mehr sehen könnte diese traumfänger
nicht mehr sehen konnten wir gar nichts
mehr sogar wir hatten ja einen strand
vom haus in dieser stadt war abgesperrt
mit einer kordel so jeder mensch über
die score darüber gehen aber wir dürfen
das ein bisschen typisch deutsche noch
nicht gemacht dürfen ja und hat nach
einigen wochen ist das ist wirklich
belasten glaube ich einfach echt
belasten vor allem wenn du auch das ist
kein kontakt zur außenwelt immer mal
wieder ein anruf so nach hause aber das
ist nicht das was du halt in deutschland
im verhältnis hat zu denen wir der
familie und ein freund ist quasi wieder
schön jva laufen alle selbst therapiert
kam hc friedrich franz i also hatte ich
irgendwann es überrascht also die
staffel im tv gesehen was mich am
meisten verwundert hat beide tatsächlich
das kommentar damals haben was die haben
mein ausstieg
okay das ist ja das was auch mit so die
runde gemacht hat man ja welches einfach
sehr nett widersprüchlich wahrzunehmen
was ich aus der vergangenheit auch von
ihnen gehört habe die menschen achten
abdeckt und ja also ich habe nicht
verstanden sagt nicole k 19 ist man bei
einem übernachtung steht alleine oder so
da trotzdem kameras
[Musik]
deswegen kann ich dazu gar nicht so viel
sagen aber die von dem was ich jetzt
auch aus vergangenen staffeln gehört
habe sind dann wirklich keine kamera
okay weil es gar neidvoll punkt 2000
hast du noch mit einer oder mehreren
batch datei über im kontakt ja ich habe
noch mit ein wenig kontakt jetzt cool
cool also silvio zu andern zu dem sie
das war nochmal so dass sie die sachen
so einprügelt ort wie auch noch kontakte
treffen uns aber noch und sonst einfach
die jessica lieferung nach dort
kennenlernen durfte und ja allein schon
für die mädels hat es sich gelohnt für
mich damit zu machen
die website ist das nicht komisch ihn zu
küssen wo er auch noch jede andere küste
hatte jeder andere geküsst
aber meine zeit ja die frage ist jetzt
vielleicht auch das hatten wir denken
über diesen themen punkten
weil das war das ein thema oder ist
einfach so wie du meintest du das
akzeptieren also da habe ich natürlich
dann auch unterschiede zum richtigen
leben gemacht
ach so es ist nicht schön natürlich
wünsche dir die einzige zu sein die ecke
das ist doch ganz klar aber du kannst
eigentlich mit dieser erwartung strobl
gefragt wurden die partei irgendwelche
vorgaben gemacht damit der streit mit
den landfrauen hast also man ist schon
das ist alles das ist alles das ist
alles relativ free ist gab es da
vielleicht mal so moment wohl so anreize
gesetzt so jetzt auch mal in die
richtung
also ich glaube aber auch selbst wenn es
so wäre müssten die us teenager keine
chance bis zum foto frage was war am
peinlichsten hast vielleicht ein meister
im moment natürlich daraus
also peinlich möchte ich das nicht
nennen ich fand es schade dass ich
eigentlich nur mit dem sebastian
zusammen kussszene gezeigt wurde was
wirklich nur gezeigt wie wir die ganze
zeit und wir uns die ganze zeit küssen
wird weil dazwischen haben natürlich
gespräche war wirtschaft so high und ein
moment weiß er noch erklären jetzt im
entwickeln dass der mir wirklich
unangenehm hätte mich als ko-könig in
welchem kontext kann und welche kameras
so richtig ausbrechen würde würde man
gesetzlich serienmörderin internet so
veghte habe irgendwas gesagt damals
sofort als jetzt hat hier in die störung
verseuchte infusionen so eine kleine
motor italien oder es ja auch nicht so
viel mit das haben wir sie gefragt wieso
bei menschen mitgemacht
ein mini paare scheinen ja indien lange
zusammen zu sein
wahrscheinlich war das ein hintergedanke
da darfst du dich mit denen paaren davor
auseinandergesetzt ob die vom letzten
jahr die macht doch zusammen youtube
videos anzusehen
ja jeder noch sehr sehr glücklich
zusammen auch ist gar nichts anderes
bachelor of arts auch über jahre hinweg
zusammen war
ja ich habe unterhalten mitgemacht weil
ich vielleicht dachte so okay man
bewirbt sich da als man wenn man
irgendwie die absicht hat sich bin und
zu wollen
ja wie gesagt wurde dann halt die kurse
dies und das und das ist okay jetzt
machst du das einfach mal so am ende
hast du nie die garantie dass eine
beziehung bis ans lebensende
ich wünsche es mir und ich glaube an die
große liebe ich glaube an ehe und ich
wünsche euch eine unfassbar dollar zu
haben kinder wirklich bis ans lebensende
aber am ende ist es halt eine erfahrung
und selbst wenn es nicht klappt es
könnte ja der mann fürs leben
so könnte sein dass erst einmal das
leben interessante frage von kimberly
marco reus detail aber fragt sie also
oder anders formuliert würdest du es
nochmal machen wenn die jetzt mit dem
wir müssen wieder anfangen wird also
auch mit dem bisschen das ausscheiden
würde
damit geben wissen wir es vielleicht
nicht meine meinung auch schon mit die
absicht hatte damit die müssen raus zu
gehen auf das jahr verteilt wird und ich
habe es mir schon gewünscht
die letzte rose zu bekommen aber erst
einmal gar nicht voran steffen haster
will ich jetzt noch mal anmelden
heute vor allem weil ich einfach
vielleicht nicht mit dem man das leben
zu hause kann man aber ich hab halt
tolle frauen kennengelernt ich habe
meine persönlichen weiterentwicklung
arbeitet in mexiko aber ich bin noch
vorsichtig wenn mich jemand fragt ob ich
empfehlen würde weil ich muss schon
sagen du musst schon ein bestimmter typ
sein und weil so etwas mitzumachen muss
damit umgehen kann mit dieser ganzen
revolution wenn ich jetzt jemanden von
der persönlichkeit her nicht so gut
kenne würde es mir schwer fallen da in
gewisser weise eine empfehlung
auszusprechen mega erfolgs sind die
männer vor der kamera so wie sie hinter
der kamera sind oder der mann bezahlte
die kamera kamera kurzem hausmittel
geholfen wird
ich habe gut die kameras sind auf ihnen
natürlich einmal darauf nun
wahrscheinlich ja
das heißt dann gab es auch außen nicht
wirklich gelegen
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich ja aber ich hatte auf
meiner position mal so sprechen ich war
so ich selbst dort vor ort aber in
eingeschränkter art und weise weil ich
einfach diese kameras ausgeschaltet
haben
und ich kann mir vorstellen dass mit
ihnen genauso was ich hätte mir
persönlich auch dieses team wird
gewünscht und ich hätte es auch
gebraucht um wirklich zu erfahren ob er
zu mir gepasst hätte weil am ende kann
er zwar die letzte rose verteilen aber
die frauen müssen natürlich auch
entscheiden hätte was du zu mir oder
nicht und diese entscheidung hätte ich
glaube ich auch nur treffen können wenn
ich noch mal zeigen und hinter der
kamera gehabt hätte weil wie gesagt es
geht halt auch einfach so private themen
über die man jetzt noch vor der ko
spielen möchte und jetzt heute ist auch
teil 2 unseres interviews zu ende teil 3
wird bald kommen wahrscheinlich in zwei
tagen hier drüben einfach vorgestellt
das via programm eco hin und unbedingt
leer abdecken nicht so in der
beschreibung verlinkt genau 3 kobalt und
bis dann